[Music]
there's a major moment that happens in
dark crisis number four where the
infinite earths return and so with that
change the actual title of the book is
going to be changing so this is moving
keeping secret from the very beginning
of this book the book is actually called
dark crisis on infinite hurts
when i knew this was going to happen it
was like whoa
really are we gonna do this crisis on
infant earth is one of my favorite uh
stories of all time being able to do a
sequel to that story to be able to do
something that is able to carry forward
that story with pariah and the infant
has just been it's been really awesome i
am also a huge fan of the
george perez titans and my woman's i
still can't believe it it's a huge honor
once you get past the q4 it gets super
nuts every single issue it's going to be
a lot of fun it's going to be a lot of
epic we have huge fights between
villains versus villains big action big
epicness you expect from a crisis it's
coming we're really excited for you to
see where we're taking the rest of the
series the ending of this series is so
massive we'll have a major impact on the
dc moving forward
you